good afternoon
president-elect biden and i just met
with some of our nation's business
and union leaders together they
represent
millions of workers across our country
and some of america's leading
technology auto and retail companies
we had an important conversation about
the impact
that this pandemic has had on workers
especially essential workers
frontline workers who have risked their
own health
and the health of their families and
many whom have given their own lives
to keep us safe and keep our economy
running and we all know that this
pandemic
and this recession have hit communities
of color particularly
hard black americans and latinos are
three times as likely
to contract kovid as others and more
likely
to die native americans are more than
four times as likely
to be hospitalized as others and last
month
the unemployment rate for black
americans was almost
twice the rate of others and we have
also had a conversation
about the impact this pandemic has had
on our economy as a whole
from the fortune 500 to the small
businesses
that so many communities rely on over
the past few months
on the campaign trail the
president-elect and i
saw that impact firsthand in state after
state
we met with workers who shared their
struggles
and told us about their pain essential
workers
who've had to stay on the job even as
they worry
about their family's well-being and
their own
small business owners who are dipping
into their own savings to make
payroll and keep their doors open and
many others
who have had to close their doors and
fear never reopening at all
their stories have stayed with us and
the president-elect and i
are focused on building our country back
better for them and all americans
and as i said the night we won this
election now
is when the real work begins the
necessary work
the good work of getting this virus
under control saving lives
and beating this pandemic and
opening our economy responsibly while
rebuilding it
so that it works for working people and
we will do it by protecting the health
and safety of our workers
and creating millions of good paying
union jobs
from auto and construction jobs to
domestic workers and caregiving jobs
to service and hospitality jobs the road
ahead
it will not be easy but the
president-elect and i
are hitting the ground running because
we all know
the challenges facing america today are
great
the american people deserve no less
and we don't have a moment to waste
and now it is my incredible and great
honor
to introduce our president-elect joe
biden
thank you very much good afternoon
vice president harris and i as she and i
just met with a group of uh america's
top business leaders and labor leaders
and i must tell you it reinforced what i
thought from beginning
ready to come together the unity was
astounded i want to go back and talk
about the people who actually
participate in that
i'm going to list all the people who you
just so you know who we spoke with
number one there was maribera
ceo of general motors brian cornell ceo
of target
mr nadel ceo of microsoft
rory gamble president of the uaw mary
kay henry president seiu
mark perrone president of ufc ufcw
lee saunders president of afscme and
sonia single president of gaap
richard trumka president of the afl-cio
it was really encouraging quite frankly
to get people
business and labor together agreeing on
the way
forward which i'm convinced the american
people we're ready to do
when they hear what we have in mind i'm
very pleased that it all came together
around the same
table to advance areas of common ground
and we agreed we're going to continue
these conversations
they represent very different
perspectives but i'm convinced that we
can all come together around the same
table
to advance areas of common ground which
are
really i wish you could have all heard
the conversation
it was really encouraging and that's
what we were ready to discuss today
we all agreed that we want to get the
economy back on track we need our
workers to be back on the job
by getting the virus under control we're
going in a very
dark winter things are going to get much
tougher before they get easier
that requires sparing no effort to fight
covet
so that we can open our businesses
safely resume
our lives and put this pandemic behind
us it's going to be difficult but it can
be done
and they all agreed that means rallying
the country behind
a national strategy with robust public
health measures
like mandatory masking widely available
testing with rapid results
scaled up production of life-saving
treatments and therapeutics
and safe equitable and free distribution
of the vaccine
it's great news that modern and pfizer
have each come up
with vaccines that are in excess of 90
effectiveness
and getting the vaccine and a
vaccination
though are two different things everyone
on our call today in our zoom today
agreed that the sooner we have access to
the administration's distribution plan
the sooner this transition would be
smoothly
move forward and you know as we battle
covert
we also make sure the business and
workers have the tools the resources
the national guidance and health and
safety standards to operate
safely and we can do that we can bring
democrats and republicans together
work with business and labor to deliver
those necessary resources
and for millions of americans who've
lost hours and wages
or have lost their jobs we all agree on
our call
that we can deliver immediate relief in
a need be done
quickly affordable health care for
millions of people who have lost it
or in danger of losing it child care
sick leave
family need so workers don't have to
choose between work and family
corporate america agreed on this today
the
provokes on the call we need support of
small to support small businesses and
entrepreneurs
that are the backbone of our communities
but are teetering on the edge
and we all agreed on the urgent need for
funding for states
and localities to keep frontline workers
and essential workers on the job
vital public services running law
enforcement
officers educators first responders like
we did in the recovery act of 2009
saving literally millions of jobs
there's a reason why the federal
government
is able to run a deficit because the
states must
must balance their budgets and they're
in real
trouble you're going to see hundreds of
thousands of police officers
firefighters first responders mental
health clinics you're going to see them
going out of business
right now congress should come together
and pass a cover relief package
like the heroes act that the house
passed six months ago
once we shut down the virus and deliver
economic relief to workers and
businesses
then we can start to build back better
than before
we talked about how we have an
opportunity to come out of this stronger
more resilient than we were when we went
in and
you i wish you could have heard
corporate leaders and the major labor
leaders
singing from the same hymnal here
throughout the campaign
i laid out my build back better plan we
laid out our plan
that an independent analysis put out by
moody's a well-respected law firm
lost a wall street firm project it would
create
18.6 million jobs
we can also we talked about the need to
own the electric vehicle market
we talked about climate a lot building
550 000 charging stations
creating over a million good paying
union jobs
here at home the need for a federal
government to invest
more in clean energy research you know
it's based on a simple premise it's time
to reward
work not just wealth in america
we're going to have a fair tax structure
to make sure the wealthiest among us and
corporations pay their fair share
our plan will create millions of good
paying union jobs
in manufacturing building the vehicles
products technologies that are gonna
we're gonna need for the future
to compete with the rest of the world
from autos to our stockpiles
we're going to buy american no
government contract
will be given to companies that don't
make their products here in america
to secure our position as a global
leader in research and development
we're going to invest 300 billion
dollars in the most critical competitive
new industries and technologies creating
three million
good paying jobs and the corporate
american technology firms like microsoft
on
the call they all agreed we can make
sure our future is made here in america
and that's good for business and it's
good for american workers
we can also modernize infrastructure
roads
bridges ports 1.5 million new affordable
housing units
high-speed broadband we talked about for
every american household
which is more important than ever from
remote learning remote working
telemedicine in the 21st century
building digital building and digital
infrastructure to help businesses
health care workers first responders and
students
a hundred billion dollars to rebuild our
crumbling schools they talked about the
need the business
community talked about the need to
invest in hbcus and community colleges
retrofitting four million new buildings
are all building retrofitting and making
them new
weatherizing two million homes building
more climate resilient cities and towns
these investments will specifically
target communities of colors
so we can break the cycle where in good
times they lag
and in bad times they get their first
they get hit first and the hardest
and in recovery it's the toughest to
bounce back
these are the kinds of investments that
are going to strengthen our economy and
our competitiveness
create millions of jobs union jobs
and in doing so i'll respect the dignity
of work
and empower the voice of workers you've
heard me say it before
my dad when he lost his job and scranton
eventually moved to wilmington
and got a good job he'd say joey a job's
about a lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity respect your
place in the community it's about being
able to look your kid in the eye and say
honey
everything's going to be okay when we
build back better
we'll do so with higher wages including
a 15
minimum wage nationwide better benefits
stronger collective bargaining rights
that you can raise a family on
that's how we build back the middle
class better than ever
that's how we make sure workers are
treated with the dignity and respect
they deserve
i can go on i can tell i was very
encouraged by our conversation
but the point is this there's so much we
can do
the only way we do any of this is if we
work together
i know we can do this for example on the
call
i made it clear to the corporate leaders
i said i want you know i'm a union guy
unions are going to have increased power
it is not it they understand
it's not anti-business it's about
economic growth creating
good paying jobs 11 years ago when
barack and i took office during the
great recession
and implemented the recovery act that
saved us from another great depression
we didn't see a map in red and blue
states
it was the united states of america we
didn't care whether the city had voted
for us or against us the state voters
forced against us
we work with everyone and we recovered
and rebuilt
together as one nation we can do this
again
the refusal of democrats and republicans
to cooperate with one another
is not due to some mysterious force
beyond our control
it's a conscious decision it's a choice
that we make
if we can decide not to cooperate then
we can decide
to cooperate i believe this is in part
the mandate for the american people part
of the mandate they gave us
they want us to cooperate they want us
to deliver results
and the choice the common i will make is
that we're going to do that
that's why i'm so pleased today we're
able to bring together business
and labor leaders to make the choice
jointly with us
we're all americans let's get to work
as i've said many times thank you may
god bless you
and may god protect our troops i
understand now i'm going to take some
questions megan
fire away
thank you president-elect biden vice
president look in the wrong direction
sorry
good to see you i want to start with a
question about uh your pandemic planning
and then a question about your economic
plan
you spoke about the need to access the
outgoing administration's covid vaccine
distribution plans
what do you see as the biggest threat to
your transition right now given
president trump's unprecedented attempt
to obstruct and delay a smooth transfer
of power
more people may die if we don't
coordinate
look as my chief of staff ron claim
would say
who handled ebola
the vaccine is important it's a little
use until you're vaccinated
so how do we get the vaccine how do we
get over 300 million americans
vaccinated
what's the game plan it's a huge huge
huge undertaking to get it done
prioritize those greatest in need
and work on our way through it and also
cooperate with the world health
organization and the rest of the world
in dealing with this
and so they say they have this warp
speed program that the not only dealt
with getting vaccines
but also how to do how to distribute
this
if we have to wait until january 20th to
start that planning
it puts us behind over a month month and
a half
and so it's important that it be done
that there be coordination
now now or as rapidly as we can get that
done
on the economy the vice president-elect
talked about having an economy
that works for working people one thing
i didn't hear you talk specifically
about
is canceling student loan debt does
student loan forgiveness
figure in your plan would you take
executive action to achieve it
it does figure in my plan i've laid out
in detail for example
the uh the legislation passed by the
democratic house
calls for immediate ten thousand dollar
forgiveness of student loan just holding
people up
they're in real trouble they're having
to make choices between paying their
student loan and paying the rent those
kinds of decisions
it should be done immediately in
addition to that if you know i think
that
everything from community college
straight through doing doubling pell
grants to making sure that we have
access
free education for anyone making under
125 000
for four years of college and there is a
program that exists now under the law
that forgives student loans for being
able to engage in
engaging in public service i'm going to
institute that fundamental change in
that so it is able to be available to
everyone
that in fact is engaged it's not being
very well managed right now so i'm going
to do all of those things
thank you
thank you mr president-elect you just
spoke of some of the dangers of the
president's continued stonewalling of
this transition but it doesn't appear
that the president is going to come
around
anytime soon and admit defeat so what
are you going to do
what options do you have to try and
ensure that you are ready to go
on day one deal with every individual
organization in the country from
business to labor
republicans democrats to try to pull
together
a serious and consistent plan
so we're ready on day one everything
from staffing to
ultimately naming cabinet members to
moving along
on coordinating with business and labor
the covet attack how we're gonna attack
covet
and uh so it would make a lot easier if
the president were to participate
you have a number of republicans
suggesting that uh
the good news here is my colleague is
still on the intelligence committee so
she gets
the intelligence briefings i don't
anymore so
uh um that
that is but there's a number of
republicans calling for that
i uh i am hopeful that the president
will
be mildly more enlightened
before we get to january 20th and what
is your message to republicans who are
backing up the president's refusal to
concede
you clearly need to work with them going
forward
my message is i will work with you i
understand a lot of your reluctance
because of
the way the president operates but um
i i've been in contact with and we'll be
in contact with more of them as we move
along
and if it has to wait until january 20th
to get actually become operational
that's a shame but maybe maybe uh that's
the only way to get it done
thank you very much
thank you very much mr president-elect
and i want to kind of piggyback off of
that i want to get your thoughts on the
president's tweet
over the weekend where he first seemed
to acknowledge that you won
then he said he won't concede then he
said i won how did you interpret that
and at the end of the day do you want
him to concede
i interpret that as trumpianism
uh no change and his modus operandi
um and uh i think the pressure will
continue to build look
i'm having
a lot of meetings with world leaders on
the on
the telephone i cannot get into
negotiating with them about things that
are going to be done but they're
calling with some degree of enthusiasm
uh
um everyone from uh
the holy father to prime ministers
across the globe um
and so we're moving along uh
knowing what the outcome will be and uh
um as i said earlier i probably
shouldn't repeat it but i
find this uh
more embarrassing for the country than
debilitating
for my ability to get started and then
secondly i want to follow up with you
on the vaccine if the fda gives
emergency
authorization to the pfizer or moderna
vaccine in the coming weeks
will you get vaccinated and if you're
hesitant
why should any american have confidence
in the vaccine
well first of all um we'll see if that
comes forward and secondly it's
important that
people who are in the greatest need get
it i wouldn't hesitate to get the
vaccine
but i also want to set
an example uh and uh
but i i wouldn't hesitate to get the
vaccine if in fact dr
dr fauci and these two organizations
whether it's moderna or
pfizer who have been extremely
responsible
conclude that it is uh it is safe and
and able to be done look the only reason
people question the vaccine now is
because of donald trump
that's the reason why people are
questioning the vaccine because all the
things he says and doesn't say whether
truthfulness and not truthful the
exaggerations i think we're on a clear
path now
we're on a clear path where the
international community and national
leaders
in the scientific community have focused
on these two vaccines
they appear to be ready for prime time
ready to be used and if that and
continues along those roads i would take
the vaccine
thank you
thank you mr president-elect you have
been urging the american public to
continue practicing social distancing
and wearing a mask but with cases
skyrocketing across the country
do you think that more governors should
be closing non-essential businesses and
reinstating stay-at-home orders
look uh it depends on the state what i
what i failed to mention earlier is the
um
the enormous respect i have for
republican conservative republican
governors who stepped up
and issued mandates for worrying mass
in north dakota you know i mean the idea
one of the leaders in this area has been
the republican governor republican and
republican governor
in ohio um and uh
in addition to the folks who've already
been leading like the governor of
of michigan i mean you know the idea
that the
president's now existing remaining
advisor on covet is saying that they
should resist
what the hell's matter with these guys
what is the matter with them
resist you know every major
individual of any consequence in the
health field
is saying we can save we can save 100
000 lives just between now and january
21st by wearing these masks
it's going to take a while for the
vaccine to be able to be available
distribute it
and get to people we're talking about
350 to 400
000 people dying i mean what are they
doing
it's totally irresponsible irresponsible
and so i complement the governors who've
stepped forward
who have been stepping forward but also
the republican governors who stepped
forward i
i i left out the governor of utah very
conservative state
governor of north dakota and all the
democratic governors have been doing it
all along
i mean it's it's uh
i i just asked a rhetorical question
do you guys understand this does anybody
understand
why a governor would turn this into a
political statement
it's about patriotism it's about being
patriotic
it's about saving life for real i'm not
it's not hyperbole
it's about being patriotic and i think
you're seeing more and more
as this god-awful virus continues to
spread
almost unabated that we
that governors are stepping up and just
following up on that especially with
many states reporting
new highs in terms of the daily number
of cases
and a lot of public health officials
sounding the alarm over the holidays
would you what is your message to people
who are considering for example getting
together with their families and others
for thanksgiving would you consider
would you urge people to reconsider
their plans well here's what i do
let me tell you what the health experts
have said to me
um and it's not because i'm unique in
president-elect it's because my family
they strongly urge that if in fact
we're going to have thanksgiving with
anyone
that we limited to a maximum
maximum they suggest five people maximum
10 people socially distanced wearing
mass
and people who have quarantined so
jill and i spent this morning like many
of you
trying to figure out what are we going
to do for thanksgiving how are we going
to do it
and we've narrowed down which family
members and that they were tested
recently tested in 24 hours and so
i would strongly urge for the sake not
just your sake for the sake of your
children your mother your father
your sisters your brothers whoever you
get together with thanksgiving
think about this there should be no
group more than 10 people in one room
at one i mean in in inside the homes
that's what they're telling me
they're telling me they're you know
making sure that that's the case
and i have the i have
the more potent mask behind this when i
took it off when i came out here i wear
it inside this
that to be masked it saves lives
and so look i just want to make sure
that
uh we're able to be here together uh
next thanksgiving uh next christmas i
mean
it's it is a
international crisis it's an
international health crisis
and the idea we're at war with the virus
and it is we're at war for real and all
kidding aside i hope all of you
i watch you all you all seem to wear
masks all the time when you're
in the and the group that follows me
that is here follows me that is assigned
to delaware with me seem to do that i
strongly urge you to do it
there's nothing macho about not wearing
a mask
thank you
thank you mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
your plan and my mask is stuck in my ear
in classic
demonstration watch jill try to take it
off it's hard i don't
i don't have an errand your plan that
you've outlined just now
about a million union jobs clean energy
jobs
investments in hbcus those are things
that take time
we have a problem with long-term
unemployment that's growing fast right
now
what would you do right away
specifically
to address jobs that may not return for
months may not return ever
including in communities of color what i
would do
i would pass the heroes act it has all
the money and capacity to take care of
each of those things
now now not tomorrow
now and the idea the president is still
playing golf and not doing anything
about it
is beyond my comprehension you at least
think he'd want to go off on a
on a positive note but what is he doing
and there's virtually no discussion and
the republican
we're told i don't know that's true you
may know
senator but there's 22 republicans say
they won't vote for anything
well there ought to be at least at least
a dozen of them have the courage to
stand up
and save lives and jobs now we should be
doing it now
keeping those businesses open providing
the ppe
the protective equipment as well as the
ppp
the money that we allow people to get
funding to keep their businesses open
everything from
separation to testing to a whole range
of things that allow businesses to open
and stay open
that's what the plan was the beginning
and by the way if you notice in the very
beginning
when they passed the stimulus program
the first two pieces
what happened peop businesses were
staying open
and then when they weren't open they
were still able to make people able to
get paid
but look where they are now people are
running out of unemployment insurance
what are they going to do 20 million
people are on the
verge of losing their home because they
can't make a mortgage payments
they have a larger number being kicked
out and will be
kicked out on the street because they
can't pay their
rent and by the way it's not just the
renter
it's the it's the outfit that owns the
building a lot of
multi-millionaires they're running small
operations
how can they do it this is about keeping
americans afloat get them through this
pandemic
get them through where they're still
their businesses are able to come back
the money's there the money is there
and also on the economic front as we
fight the pandemic
world trade continues and there is great
debate over world trade agreements
international trade agreements
uh it seems that we in the last couple
of days 15 countries
asian pacific countries have signed on
to a new trade deal the rcep
should the united states consider
joining that trade agreement
i've talked with a number of these world
leaders and i told them
under the law i'm not able to begin to
discuss with them there's only one
president at a time
as to who can say what our policy will
be
so i'm reluctant to answer that question
now but here's i can say
we make up 25 of the world's trading
capacity of the economy of the world
we need to be aligned with the other
democracies
another 25 percent or more so that we
can set the rules of the road
instead of having china and others
dictate
outcomes because they are the only game
in town
and so but what i'm insisting on
and what i've been asked by world
leaders as to what i would do without
getting into detail i've said but i want
you to know
that there are three things going to
happen if i'm elected
one we're going to invest in american
workers to make them more competitive
number two we're going to make sure that
labor
is at the table and environmentalists
are at the table
and any trade deals we make and i'm not
looking for puna to trade
the idea that we are poking our finger
in the eyes of our friends
and embracing autocrats makes no sense
to me
and so but i'm reluctant to get in more
detail
at this moment i promise you i have a
pretty thorough plan
and i will be prepared to announce that
to you on january 21st
you have indicated changes you want to
make in u.s international policy on
other fronts like the paris climate
yes that's a generic notion of rejoining
but i didn't get into the detail of what
we'll do in that agreement
i the same thing with rejoining the
world health organization
uh why not here because you're you're
asking me about whether i join a
specific proposal
the details of what you're now only
being negotiated among those nations
it would require a negotiation
thank you thank you
appreciate it
hey
this one
you